president putin's parade in moscow came
just hours after russian forces
allegedly bombed a school where dozens
of civilians were sheltering in the east
of the country local officials estimate
at least 60 people were killed charlie
dagda is in ukraine for us as well
charlie what more can you tell us
well jerica many people are already
calling the attack on the school a war
crime and this is where the consequences
of president putin's decisions are
played out in the cities and towns all
along the front line
reduced to burning and smoldering rubble
in what ukrainian authorities say was a
direct hit the school where terrified
families sought shelter from russia's
bombardment we have found evidence of
indiscriminate shelling everywhere we've
gone the battle scarred village of
velika nova silca sits right on the
warpath of the russian advance from the
south a us defense official says 10 000
russian soldiers are now on the move
north of mariopol and they're massing on
the outskirts of this village which has
clearly come under repeated attack
we came upon irina ilyenko and her
neighbor valentina hajnova surveying the
ruins of their homes
amid the constant crack
of mortar fire and artillery
does that happen a lot
are you going to try to lead now
she says she can't leave her bedridden
husband behind whatever god has prepared
for me she said let it be
to the northeast the city of kramatorsk
is also in the firing line residential
neighborhoods devastated by russian
firepower in the ruins children's toys
and other personal belongings more lives
torn apart in putin's relentless drive
to seize this region of eastern ukraine
now ukrainian forces have been able to
slow down the russian advance but
they've got little defense against this
artillery and airstrike airstrikes and
that is only intensified by the day
nate
charlie dagda in ukraine thank you